while you'd be here awaiting Humanity's
Doom
Uranus would start shaking things up
because Uranus is about 15 times more
massive than the Earth
its gravitational pull would start
massively affecting our planet
volcanoes would begin erupting
uncontrollably and tremendous
earthquakes would get in on the ACT
destroying the Earth from the inside
think
you drop unconscious from even one whiff
of it because well I mean Uranus smells
like farts
the ice Giant's upper atmosphere is
mostly composed of hydrogen sulfide it's
the same stuff that makes rotten eggs
reek so bad
imagine an entire planet of rotten eggs
engulfing the Earth
yeah
the thought of it makes me nauseous